well Matt honey that's amazing to see
you as well let's get it Dalton here we
go sir how do you feel when a patient
dies what's the biggest fight you've
been in which war did you five him
that's a good one we ran out of water
three days toward the end to the point
where people were passing out and
fainting sometimes I think it's hard not
to feel that you felt I mean I get
people look angry but I've actually done
this to myself it's somebody pulled a
weapon on you you etta then you were sad
know why she said what do you want gem
pound I said have won the jackpot
there was forty-four thousand
anti-aircraft guns so it was a matter of
luck when you got hit or not
[Music]
I'll have my finger amputated I love it
you've got to be a certain Kyla
bottom-up simple as that people can see
that they can't see what's going on in
your head it was almost as though if you
weren't a friend before you couldn't be
a friend after last moments of life is
quite special I feel like this is the
real me because I'm like screaming out
look at all this thank you for your
service and everything that you did it's
been really good talking to you
you